okay why don't we go ahead and get
started thank you all for coming I'm
actually going to make two introductions
today one is actually to tell tell you
about a new activity of the department
of medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology and then my second
introduction will be our guest of honor
so the first thing I'm going to tell you
about is a new initiative and demise
called the informatics discovery lab I
know some of you know a little bit about
it but it represents our efforts in the
department to reach out to take on new
work consistent with our mission that
has a different audience besides
government funders and the other usual
sources and the just to quote the
mission for the informatics discovery
lab is to provide leadership discovery
and dissemination of knowledge in
clinical informatics clinical
epidemiology and bioinformatics and
computational biology and we fulfill the
mission through research education
collaboration and service the IDL effort
is being spearheaded by one of our
faculty dr. Aaron Cohen who many of you
know and part of this effort is bringing
in some outside speakers who not only
have subject expertise and aspects of
informatics but also experience in these
sorts of activities and so we've invited
our guest today dr. Atul Butte from
Stanford who is here to not only meet
with us to talk about our next steps
with the IDL but also to give a public
talk and inform you of some very
exciting work that he does that is well
certainly if you look at what's going on
at ohsu is also the direction that ohsu
is taking which is the kind of
integration of genomics and in medicine
and related areas a very data-driven
future dr. Butte is associate professor
of pediatrics at Stanford he is chief of
the division of systems medicine in the
department of pediatrics he also has
numerous other appointments in
departments around campus in genetics
computer science and medicine and he is
initially trained in computer science
and spent some time in industry and then
went to medical school at Brown
University where he graduated in 1995 he
then did a residency and and fellowship
in residency in pediatrics fellowship in
pediatric endocrinology at Children's
Hospital in Boston and then joined the
informatics training program at Harvard
where he got a PhD at in the health
sciences and technology program the
joint program between MIT and Harvard
Medical School he then moved on to
Stanford where he has led a very
successful research program and he is
going to tell us about the work that
he's doing he he was we originally going
to have this talk in our usual setting
which is the big theatre which many of
you know but we were kicked out of there
by the bring your child to work day but
a tool actually tells me that that
that's actually quite relevant and some
of the things he's going to talk about
deal with children so I will turn it
over to a tool and great now thank you
very much thanks for the introduction
I'm just gonna start with an apology
I've been in this field for 15 years
it's actually my first time actually
finally visiting your campus it's about
time so I humbly apologize for my
delayed arrival here first it's a
medical talk so you always got start
with the disclosures I started a bunch
of companies I consult for a bunch of
companies now my average grad student
starts a company you shouldn't believe
in other word I say
but hopefully I'm going to convince you
by the end of this talk to start a
company as well especially if your
junior folk person here all right so if
you haven't heard we're in the middle of
this data delusion let's to start with
these delusions and tsunamis a special
issue of economists magazine two years
ago the cover was the data to luge and
in that issue it says that we as a human
species now generate 20 bytes of data
per year 20 bytes if you have forgotten
your metric prefixes it goes kilo mega
Giga terabyte Petta exa zettabytes and
of course next year we has human species
will join for zettabytes because it's
doubling every year and of course the
vast majority this are random kittens
playing piano videos I grant you that
that not all of the zetas bites are
useful but they're entertaining perhaps
a lot large competitive internet
traffic's netflix i acknowledge all that
but there's a lot of data out there to
data that we can operate on in science
and there's data for particle physics Oh
Large Hadron Collider comes up with
petabytes we have the NASA Sky Survey
which takes such detailed pictures of
the sky not enough scientists even look
at it they crowd-sourced I to get the
internet community to help look at the
sky pictures see what's out there and we
in fact have so much data now let's let
people including Chris Anderson whose
energy for wired to write this article
wire no wire it is not the most
scientific of journals but this this
article intrigued me that we collect so
much data now we collect so much data
that science itself is growing obsolete
okay and there's going to be a theme for
the talk here how can you say science is
growing up sleep because remember the
good ol fashioned scientific method
scientific method is you come up with a
question or hypothesis and then you go
make measurements to address that
question or address that hypothesis and
now we're in a world where we already
have the measurements we have so many
measurements the new magic I'm talking
about figure out what's the question we
want to ask what do we want to do with
this data and once you figure that out
actually the code kind of even writes
itself but what do we want to ask that
everyone wants to know the answer to and
nobody realizes is askah bond we have
the tools to ask an answer today so i'm
going to show you this kind of approach
of coming up with questions given the
data I
bc it's not just particle physics and
astronomy tson life science research as
well another great article in harvard
business review by the way if your
junior faculty starting a lab i highly
recommend reading the Harvard Business
Review talks about how to deal with
prima donnas that tells about how to
manage teams of innovators it's great
magazine freaking expensive but it's a
great journal you know the next
Scientific Revolution moving from theory
in the you know the Greeks and the
Chinese experimentation seventeen
hundreds simulations and computers and
think about models model organisms the
1900s in our data mining the 2000s
nature says it's shameful if we don't
use the data that's out there science
says we need to make data max will be
available and even know Lance it says if
we don't share research data it's an
impediment to public health what kind of
data am I talking about a lot of it
comes from high-throughput measurements
in molecular biology today on the left
here is just one example of such a
technology this is one source of all
this data on the left is just a standard
aphro metrics gene chip this is a chip
that's the size of your thumbnail here's
your thumbnail here is a chip and this
chip lets us quantitate every gene in
the genome we all know this this
quantity its RNA the blueprints not the
DNA not the protein in between the RNA
and this let's just quantitate every
gene in the genome on a single chip now
of course we love to scale in life
science so we wonder we want to scale
this up we make 96 wells of things and
each well here is one of these chips and
now we can measure them 96 at a time
each well here is this chip that lets
digitally measure every every gene in
the genome this is an amazing technology
you have to admit still looks kind of
cool by design it kind of looks like an
Intel microprocessor they're based in
Santa Clara not too far from our Intel
side of things in Silicon Valley but
it's amazing and we got to remember this
today is a commodity item most people
don't even care what company they're
ordering from anymore affymetrix agilent
alumina it's only about two to three
hundred dollars now for each one of
these chips in fact it's been like this
now we've had these chips for 15 years
already we've had microwaves 15 years
everyone knows about microwaves everyone
uses microwaves and what happened in
early 2000s and everyone started writing
papers about microwaves right here's
Alyssa jeans are different that cancer
here's a list of genes are different in
this
in this metabolic disease and everyone
started putting out here's a list of
genes there's a list of genes and what
happened is that journalist took
leadership here in the journals came
outside hold on a second guys guys and
gals no more papers on microwaves no
more okay that's it unless you start to
deposit your data into an international
repository so other people can kind of
double check your math and it's getting
increasingly important to double check
some of that microwave math that we're
getting closer to the clinic and maybe
someday someone else can use the samples
for something else and the precedent for
this goes back to GenBank right with DNA
sequences nobody wants to type in DNA
sequences from a paper that's why I
genbank is not 29 years old okay we've
had GenBank for a long time the same
precedent happens for other micro and
other measurement technologies as well
another kick though comes from these
policy so those who write grants and
have to reapply for grants know that as
we write papers not what microwaves are
otherwise we have to make our papers
open access now within a year and we've
always had this at NIH the white house
two months ago said you know what
actually now all funding agencies in the
government have to make their papers
available in a year not just NIH it was
not a big deal for us lot of folks in
our community said oh they're selling
out they should make these papers
available on arrival I am NOT going to
argue any of that one thing of people
didn't catch in all of these White House
announcements is that you got to make
the data available to not just the
papers okay it's going to be a new world
for us to think about raw research data
getting out there we have these
precedents but you're going to see more
of it so everyone knows what a my career
is and most people know you have to
share that data when you write a paper
how much data is actually publicly
available today and in last August
August first natured is special article
it featured my lab couple others as of
August first last year we hit 1 million
publicly available microwaves now 1
million of them here's the exponential
growth trajectory kind of looks like
it's flattening off here only because
they counted half the year okay still
doubling every two to three years how
much microdata is out there and to kind
of make it really kind of obvious if you
go to the NCBI we all know pub
ed some of us know genbank well here's a
repository for this kind of data ncbi
geo gene expression omnibus almost
900,000 raised there right now if you
look this couple weeks old the Europeans
run a repository called ray express they
got another quarter million actually
today we're already blown past 1.1
million right 1 million was all the way
back in august that's eons ago we're
already got another hundred thousand
arrays here now let me just make it
painfully obvious what this means to all
of us in this audience in the middle of
this website is a simple search box all
right some of you've heard me say this
in talks maybe you haven't even a high
school kid today maybe who's here for
back to school back though see your
parents at work day right a high school
kid day it needs to a science fair
project right she can type breast cancer
here and now digitally download 34,000
digital samples of breast cancer about
as easy as she can find a song on iTunes
ok 1300 plus independent experiments
here contributing this data now let's
just kind of make this obvious if it's
not obvious to you 34 thousand samples
why is that interesting because that's
more samples of breast cancer then any
breast cancer researcher will ever have
in their lab because everyone lab has to
share their data plus their competitors
so wherever figures out how to get to
the middle is going to have more samples
now than anyone else okay especially as
most of the contributing people don't
know how to get data out of this system
they only know how to put data in and
let me just point out the 1300 lat so
let me let me just reverse this for a
second year right let's I came to you
with an amazing grant proposal I'm going
to do this amazing grant but I'm going
to get 1,300 of the best breast cancer
researchers in the world I'm going to
ask them all to do all the experiments
are great at doing it strained breast
cancer maybe it's cell lines or mouse
models or human samples and I'm going to
get all 1,300 my best friends my best
the best people in the world to run my
grace to share the data with me and
actually I'm not even to pay them a
dollar on my grant right so kids today
would call that crowdsourcing right in
the really old days I was like Tom
Sawyer right getting your friends to
paint the fence right
now they called crowdsourcing so
imagined crowdsourcing the 1300 best
breast cancer labs not paying them a
dollar and getting all their data you
laughed me out of the room if I propose
that yet what i'm doing here is retro
actively crowdsourcing the crowd is
helping me with their best research
findings and they don't even know
they're helping me and I'm not even the
one hitting them with the stick making
them share this data and nobody's really
using this data at all today now if you
have any doubts high school kid can do
this I'm most proud of my five high
school kids during their summers out of
either one they Intel Westinghouse or
Siemens semi-finalists or even made all
the way to the finals he was number two
science kid in the country each one of
these kids was one of the top 300 kids
in science in high school of their
respective years a high school kid can
absolutely do magic with 10,000 20,000
samples of breast cancer prostate cancer
whatever disease you want the data is
sitting there waiting for someone to
analyze it and ask a question now this
is on RNA side you know the DNA side is
just the same way you have to share the
data to DB gap the rules a little bit
more severe you had to get permission
sometimes but the data is being shared
across the board oh I'm not even
counting in this the Cancer Genome Atlas
beautiful set of currently 18,000 cancer
samples including yet another 860 breast
cancer samples of your interest in
breast cancer but of course here they
don't just have the RNA they have the
RNA seek they have the DNA changes in
the oncogenes they have the methylation
they've copy number changes in the DNA
and the histopath images and the
mammography okay everything from the
diagnostic radiology to the Micra and
all the different molecular measurements
and they give this data away imagine how
you can be a person coming in connecting
the imaging to the molecular site right
things that cook each one of these
cancers is written in a big nature paper
i grant you to get their nature paper
and then they move on to the next one
right and all that data is sitting there
no one really uses it for much and it's
up to you to think about what you want
to do with this if we're talking a drug
side here because I know we have some
drug discussions come up later here's
another repository even fewer people use
called pubchem to show
of hands how many people have heard of
pubchem some of my goodness 34 people
max pubchem is another repository what
happened in the roadmap initiative
formalize or hunie Cerrone said you know
we need to get academics starting to
think about drug development not to make
them full Pharma at least start to pay
for screening tests and these are
screening tools where maybe you have a
cancer that glows of its living or glows
of its dying you put them in wells you
test different drugs with robots and
these are screening assays but and I
each said if we're funding you to do a
screening ass here to develop a
screening assay you gotta dump your date
into pubchem fast for ten years later
what is pubchem think of a grid of a
hundred million chemicals as the columns
many which are drugs or future drugs
650,000 screening assays bioassays of
the rows if you do the math there that's
about 70 trillion little boxes of which
a billion of them have some poor
scientists somewhere made a measurement
and stuck it in this whole system now
I'm willing to bet any one of you this
doesn't probably just beat the screening
database of a pharmaceutical company I'm
willing to bet this probably beats them
all combined this is more Diaz public
available i'm willing to bet you then
all pharmaceutical companies combined
because this is doubling every two to
three years again and nothing in pharma
discovery is doubling it that rate
anymore and they give this to you
without a user ID and password just
sitting there are all these drugs
chemical properties waiting for
something to do something magical with
of course i got to be really a big fan
of this one import this one I took over
in january thirty million dollar grant
basically from the NIAID allergy
infectious disease they have their stick
that says if you're funded by an iad you
got to share your data in a repository
but this has a lot of data doesn't have
any other home like flow cytometry data
site off novel ways to sort cells and to
look at their cell properties and that's
grain that's another repository i've had
this grand for 90 days and what I
realize this data is going to be about
is just completely change my perspective
on everything the best thing that's
going to come out of import and maybe
other repositories in the future the
best thing or it's going to be raw
clinical trials data this is going to be
the next big revolution for us okay i
don't mean the summary statistics
you're mandated to put into clinical
trials gov I mean imagine having
individual patient level process like
how did this patient do in this trial
which arm were they in what were their
outcomes imagine being able to reanalyze
and meta-analyses in trials without
being a part of those trials imagine the
future appt of the future where a
patient can say boy I most closely
resemble this patient in this trial what
happened to this one and that one those
are things we can't even imagine today
that we're going to be possible to get
raw trials data and so this can be one
of the first repository have we already
have three trials of data out there
waiting for you to play with now this is
great we can start to get to this data
we construct to turn our computational
crank we got our methodology and we can
start to make get ideas we can get ideas
like you know this is a great drug that
might work on this disease or here's a
good blood test for this particular
disease that tell me who's gonna get
this disease and then all of a sudden we
hit a wall we had a wall how do we as
computational folks convince our basic
biology friends or clinical scientists
friends to test these ideas because we
can come up with ideas you know 100 a
day 100 an hour and sometimes it's lost
and folks why they should actually
pursue these to test them in the lab and
we all have good friends and
collaborators you have great cancer
centers here we have them to a certain
point you have ideas and you're not able
to find people to test these ideas and
then what I'm going to show you in the
next few slides it's going to be perhaps
even more eye-opening to you so the
other day we had this prediction we use
some of our own data some public data we
came up with a good serum protein test
for acute myeloid leukemia not a good
look II me to have perhaps one of the
bad ones we talked about having a bone
marrow transplantation maybe this would
be a good test to see who's going to
relapse or not but we go to our Cancer
Center where NCI funded which they do we
have any saved serum or plasma on
patients with acute myeloid leukemia and
we're you know we're NCI doesn't we have
a biorepository but turns out they saved
all the cancer cells you saved all the
cells and RNA from these cancers and
that's great but they never saved the
liquid around the cells the serum or the
plasma and it's a strategic decision
takes more freezers you got to save them
all they say that's okay go get our B
approval go put up the posters we all
have posters recruiting patients and you
should have enough patience in a year to
test your computational prediction and
what is a computational guy like me do
we just google for it and we find
companies like this conversent biol
browse by disease I see pictures of
vacutainer 'he's what do i want to buy
today bladder cancer brain cancer breast
cancer okay here's leukemia there's
lupus rheumatoid arthritis what exactly
do I want to purchase CD nike+ B cells
from bone marrow cd45 positive cells
from bone marrow mononuclear cells from
bone marrow t-cells negative selection
from bone marrow page 2 here's plasma
from peripheral blood from leukemia $55
each army samples you want per patient
what disease subtype how many units add
to cart what is this this stuff shows up
in 48 hours on dry ice ready for you to
go what is this these are huge hospitals
in middle of a country that get more
tests on their patients right and you
know you probably know when a doctor
nurse orders a blood test that blood
sample sits in a freezer for 48 hours
waiting for them to add something more
to the test and at the end of 48 hours
to make room that sample has get thrown
out it gets incinerated legally
something magically happens when it
leaves a freezer on the way to the trash
that is now called a discarded sample
and legally you can strip off the
identifiers put on some basic clinical
characteristics we as customers have to
agree we're not going to try to reify
these people I don't really care who
these people are but then we can
purchase and they've those companies
organize these samples resell them for
research to use and you get these in 48
hours now why am i chuckling at this is
this is way faster and cheaper than my
own institution can deliver these
samples right so I'm not against my
institution having a bio bank but it
better be faster cheaper better than
what I can get off the internet today
okay $55 we just order them all and we
validate our markers this way and you
know those core facilities on campus
nobody ever said we in from informatics
can't use them either I don't want this
stuff to show up to my offices and
cubicles I wanted to go
directly to port facility we're having a
fire now my remarks weren't that
incendiary yet but they'll get there
hahaha it's amazing that the alarms
aren't going off in this room so that's
a that's perhaps a blessing and a curse
as we burn down okay so pathology
samples I could tell you could buy two
microwaves you can buy pathology samples
for a couple hundred dollars like if you
have questions I can go into details but
then the ultimate okay we have this
great data we have our tools we come up
with ideas for drugs right maybe we
think this drug might work on this
disease or this drug might work on that
condition how do you test that well we
can go try do a run a trial we can go
find our friends in animal facility or
we can just go to sa depot dot-com okay
the folks are chuckling recognize this
sounds like home depot okay for good
reason what do you want to buy today
biology chemistry drug metabolism
pharmacokinetics let's click on
pharmacology what type of mouse do you
want to run today bone carteret skoda
dermatology diabetes in your infectious
disease information neurology cancer i
ear pain respiratory i'm a diabetes guy
is click on diabetes okay here's a
standard 16 mouse experiment obie obie
mouse model you have to know this mouse
has been eating a lot and getting
diabetes since nineteen fifty-one kind
of teaches you that this is one of
standard models to see to look at
obesity induced diabetes and now if you
have an idea for a drug you can order
the drug from one catalog the mouse from
this website and you have two groups of
eight or four groups of four over 28
days they'll measure the insulin and the
blood sugar levels and they email you
back all experimental data what am i
covering up with yellow the price nine
thousand dollars for this service nine
week turnaround time and now literally
add to shopping cart that entire Mouse
experiment whether you want primate
Mouse rats the entire animal experiment
is purchasable with e-commerce today
okay you can buy entire mouse experiment
with a decent size credit card we do
this like crazy in my lab now some of
you with sharp eyes have noticed this
one's run in china and some of you may
have a problem with that some of you not
but
she in reality when he could add to
shopping cart you actually present with
133 companies that know how to offer
this to you including Maryland Wisconsin
and places all over the world so
outsourcing doesn't mean offshoring okay
you can have the place be wherever you
want it to be but actually maybe you
only want to see that USDA approved
companies just for FDA five iso9001
seven triple a lack 28 you click on
certifications here you're only going to
see those companies with those
certifications oh how i wish i could
pick my collaborators on campus this way
knowing how certified they really were
they put is a random grad street on this
thing right now some of you are dying to
ask me at this point what about the
quality of the results here right the
mouse the drug this is probably most
important part of your experiment here
how do you really trust this company to
give you good quality results i'll
simply answer that if you truly care
about the answers from this type of
company are the results you get back
simply order two of them one from the
east coast one from the west coast right
that's what we do you guys see examples
of that why am i being so flippant about
this because think about the random
biologists that runs a mouse experiment
they get it working in their lab now how
many of them go across the hall and say
can you repeat my whole experiment
without me to see if this works in your
lab nobody does that so now quality for
me is a function of dollars if I want
really the best to know this drug works
i'll spend more money on this right I
just need to see if it works all over
one of them nine thousand dollars or 25
of them you really want to know if this
drug is working you just spend more
money get more independent labs during
this experiment so I will always win the
quality argument now okay because it's
just a matter of getting more dollars
here that's kind of true the trick here
now the few basic scientists that are in
the room here the basic biologist here
might say you know you look at this
price nine thousand dollars 4016 mice
that's incredibly expensive okay and
that's true because those basic
biologists have slaves I mean graduate
students they actually you can do this
work for much cheaper than nine thousand
dollars right we think about us as
computational dry bench Reese
right if you visit my lab it's all
office and cubicles the wettest thing we
have is the coffee machine okay office
in cubicles for us to get a mouse thing
done is impossible and so this is
priceless for us to get this kind of
data here so let's fast forward to the
bench to bedside problem actually right
you think about the translational
pipeline how we make clinical molecular
measurements increase with sequencing or
microwaves we asked a good question or
trial we run our statistical
computational methods to analyze the
data with this question mine we then
validated in the second phase let's say
a drug or a biomarker I'm just simply
going to say today in this pipeline
three out of these four are commodity
items or services today we're sitting on
a million microwaves just on the RNA
side we have plenty of computational
methods look I'm a computational guy but
I have to admit our field just keeps
churning out more and more methods and
it's not really clear why someone else
will hit our website now compared to
someone else's there are plenty of
websites okay if you really built a
great killer website show people you
find with it not just that it's a
website I mean that you can see that
theme towards the end and now I can
validate that set that second phase a
drug or bar marker with a credit card to
buy samples to get this done so let's
take this to an extreme in my part of
the country in Silicon Valley we're so
used to starting huge companies and
garages right Apple and HP are the
famous ones we start companies in dorm
rooms google yahoo of course facebook
starts at a dorm room out in Harvard I
really truly believe the next Genentech
the next Amgen is going to start in your
garage your next big pharmaceutical
companies going to be in your garage
right I'm not talking about making meth
okay in your garage okay I'm talking
about an Amgen Tour genetic the next big
biotech but I'm calling garage biotechs
when you go home today and you look at
your garage you already have 1 million
microwaves and every mouse model in the
world available from your garage what
else do you need to get started with the
biotech company right of course there's
a lot of hard work after that but what
else you need to get started here it's a
little bit of investment a decent that
equals a decent sized credit card you
got all the data and computational chops
and a little bit of brain power to know
what to do next year so I'm just going
to give you anecdotes
of how we've been doing this here and so
the first example I want to talk about
is to go right after this kind of a big
picture going after public health
menaces my lab we love going after
public health menaces this paper came
out in pnas last summer it's a little
bit more molecular and I will talk about
some clinical stuff type 2 diabetes is a
public health Menace a third of all kids
the United States are going to get type
2 diabetes if they were born after year
2000 there's a problem where the insulin
doesn't work as well in a body we've
known about diabetes forever for at
least a hundred years we've known about
insulin we still come up with new drugs
all the time we have this new category
drugs at kemah 2008 dpp-4 inhibitors I'm
just giving this as an example drug
we've had drugs for 50 years 60 years
but even new drugs show up on the market
and the first year sales are immediately
a billion dollars it's already a six
billion dollar market that's how badly
we still need new drugs and diabetes
okay I'm gonna focus on diabetes for the
next few slides and I'm going to end
like everyone else we had a microwave
paper this was back when I was at
Harvard almost one hundred a hundred
almost ten years ago seems like a
hundred years ago where's diabetic
muscle use non diphu class i'll run them
on my crazed hundred genes different big
deal okay everyone had paper like this
now one paper is not going to be enough
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
if you have any kind of interest in this
kind of way of doing science just
remember this paper Nature Methods april
twenty two thousand nine what explain
this paper because nobody really
recognize this paper this paper says
portioning standardization signs it
comes from the mouse psychiatrists think
about those two words together okay the
mouse psychiatrist those are folks who
wrote this paper and you soon you can
imagine people use mouse models for
anxiety and depression and all these
folks were saying point man well when we
run experiments Stanford we get these
jeans and when they run experiment
Harvard they get those jeans and these
jeans are not matching we're not getting
reproducible results in Mouse psychiatry
I said this is ridiculous we need to
standardize how we study mouth
psychiatry this is what it means have
anxiety this is what it means have
depression and you got put the mouth in
this maze and do this with that and now
all a sudden everyone's getting the same
answers that's you would imagine that's
what standards do the harvard law at
Stanford everyone's getting the same
entrance these are the
genes that are showing up and then a
problem happens the minute they change
one parameter in the standard way of
doing experiment this kind of mouse to
that kind of mouse one mouse / cage two
mice per cage this diet bat died give
them something to play with give them
water and less water the minute you
change one aspect of the standard
protocol none of the answers hold up
they're not generalizable so we in the
computational world know what they did
they over fit their model they said if
you do the experiment exactly this way
of course you get the same answer but
the answer is actually irrelevant if you
just change one parameter there this
controversial paper came out and said
why on earth do we keep insisting we
standardize things in science we should
deliberately try a hundred ways to do
this experiment and then figure out
what's in common in the end right what
sticks out at the end maybe not everyone
gets the same answer but there's stuff
that's in common in the end this paper
totally resonated with me because we can
do this in silico with the world's data
and so now I'm not so uptight about did
they do the same experiment here I just
want everyone to do the best experiment
they know how to do in diabetes and then
figure out what's in common that's the
model here so fast forward to today
instead of one random microwave paper I
look on the internet I find a hundred
and thirty papers in this field 130
experiments I don't even need to write a
single author I can get their data off
the internet where everyone's look the
diabetes and control diabetes and
control diabetes and control but they
might look that liver muscle fact beta
cells it sounds I make the insulin rat
mouse or human three species for tissues
simple question what's in common even a
high school kid I can prove to you in
highschool clique can do this what's in
common across all these models well
let's just look at the background here's
a grid that goes from zero whoop going
too fast 0 to about 130 or so would be
out here these are just 25,000 genes in
the genome it's kind of not hard almost
twenty-five percent of the genes and
genomes show up in one person's
experiment okay that's how much noise
there is here a lot of genes show up
it's gets harder though to show up at 20
experiments 40 experiments
experiments you can kind of see a tail
dropping off here we got many known
genes for type 2 diabetes including PPR
gamma drug target left arrows up to
those OB mice tcf 72 g wasps hits all
I'm trying to show here is that the
known genes show up shifted over to the
right compared to all the rest of the
genes in the genome and you can put a
p-value in this I'm not even going to
scare you away with the p-value so we're
looking at this we're looking at this
we're looking ATS we're just simply
noticing what's this tiny little red dot
out here this is a gene i'm going to
call gene a for the moment that shows up
in 78 experiments and it's in more
people's experiments than any other gene
in the genome and it's never been chased
down for diabetes okay i will look at
gene a gene a gene a it's got an
interesting symbol it's a CD molecule
okay like cd4 cd8 maybe clinicians have
heard of those two that means that it's
a gene that codes for a protein that
sits on a cell surface and some
immunology at one point in history could
flow sword cells based on you could sort
cells based on this surface protein and
then we're staring at it we're staring
at we're realizing it's not just a cell
surface protein it's a functional
receptor so that means other things by 2
and turn things on and off in the cell
and in fact the ligand the thing that
binds the receptor is gene be and that's
this red dot here so we got sitting in
everyone's data a brand new receptor for
type 2 diabetes okay so we got start
chasing this down and we enter this
great collaboration with University of
Tokyo and for other institutions in
Japan rican keio university Cassano
university can assign a medical school
and we had a lot of folks helping us
with the mice but where we didn't have
someone helping us with device you know
how i'm getting the my stuff done now
okay so where do we even start well
let's go ask the database that everybody
says well it chased this thing down into
fat the fat really seems to change this
receptor a lot and in fact ninety
percent of the fat experience where the
receptor change the like it also changed
so it's part of what we call an
autocrine effect so now let's show you
fat pictures you can see how we can get
the stuff done with collaborators or by
just buying this there's this normal fat
high fat diet just take fat that gene
does go up by RNA stain you get pretty
pictures of fat and you
is a receptors in these inflammatory
cells it's not a fat cell problem that
fat has inflammatory cells are immune
cells in there and that's what's making
these receptor happen to be macrophages
there have been no idea but immunology
ligand-receptor are coexpressed as we
predicted here the very next step the
biologists would do is say wow that's
kind of interesting maybe we got see
what this thing does let's go make a
knockout mouse let's gonna make a mouse
that's missing this receptor and lo and
behold you look in the Jackson labs
website the Jackson labs we're all good
knockout mice go to live and die Jackson
labs website some immunologists knocked
out this receptor 11 years ago malice is
at Jackson labs and they never looked at
the sugar level of the mouse okay you
have to fast the mouse I know how to do
that nobody looked at a fasting blood
sugar for this mouse six thousand
dollars later we have the mouse okay
let's look at the mouse staying for
macrophages fewer of them this
quantities that you can see that by I
but how's it do functionally turns out
this mouse is insulin sensitive let me
see tell you what that means you not cut
this receptor it doesn't die from
diabetes it does better than the control
mouse okay it's more insulin sensitive
whether it's normal fat high-fat diet
fasting blood sugar glucose test insulin
test the mouse's insulin sensitive at
the same way so it's not a weight issue
here now that tells us boy if we knock
out this receptor maybe that could be a
great therapeutic target someday for
humans for diabetes I mean it's brand
new receptor here and knocking it out
seems to do better well let's go back to
humans let's see if humans have this how
do we test human fat oh can I tell you
how easy it is to buy human fat off the
internet it's called liposuction 57 year
old woman BMI 37 you can guess where
this fat came from we don't know who
this person we don't care loaded with
cells with this receptor okay it's not
even subtle in fact humans make so much
of this receptor there's a soluble form
it disconnects from the cells it just
floats in the blood and you can buy that
Eliza kit for 500 bucks it turns out the
level in the blood correlates with
something called a hemoglobin a1c that
is the blood test we run on diet
medics to see what the sugar levels are
and again lower is better lower is
better so $500 a kit these 55 folks by
the way don't even have diabetes yet so
as it's going up the a1c is going up or
vice versa but the mouse tells us it's
probably causal that way and it actually
has to do an insulin resistance if
you're really diabetes aficionados you
know what a home ir is so everything is
telling us get rid of this receptor
knock it out or hit it it's going to
make a great drug we said oh man let's
just go right to the punch line let's
make a brand new drug so what's a
simplest drug you can make well here's a
receptor here's an anti receptor
antibody okay let's just treat my foot
and a receptor antibody and the control
gets isotype control other antibodies
random other an advice in about a week
we can wipe out that infiltrate not a
hundred percent maybe some T cells there
who knows and we can lower the blood
sugar in seven days so now let's recap
we got brand new prototype drug for type
2 diabetes currently affecting 150
million worldwide a third of all kids
the United States will get this disease
last new drug hit a billion dollars
first year sales we got new prototype
drug new mechanism of action of getting
disease new mechanism of therapy to
treat it we got the knockout mice
immunohistochemistry remember that blood
test company at Genentech might call
that a serum companion diagnostic so we
know when it's high we can even watch it
perhaps go down we started with the same
data any high school kid can get to
today okay that's the story here write
the data sitting there by definition
means 78 people missed this receptor
because when people run experiments they
love to see what they know and if I say
oh that's as inflammatory schmutz in
there right probably causal here right
that's the thing is that probably has
more to do it just be the noise here
we've done this meant of by the way what
is the receptors called cd44 and holler
are cancer receptor those are your
breast cancer research or maybe an
audience know that we actually have end
I cd44 development because it's all of a
sudden the press as being a cancer stem
cell marker of all things now I'm going
to say it's a complicated receptor a lot
of exons alternative splice maybe the
receptor and breast cancers different
than the diabetes tissues who knows
we'll see what how this drug does but
this it's complicated scepter we can do
all sorts of fun bye
LG I'm not going to be the one to do the
biology I'm a computational person I'm
an informatics person I get the launch
here we'll get drugs spun out of this
thing and we're off to the next disease
okay but we're going to launch biology
we're going to but we're starting from a
huge point here that's that's the way
they could do this now you know we start
to realize instead of doing this just
for one disease like a diabetes why
don't we just start to do it for all the
different diseases and so actually my
first big NIH grant was just go get
every human disease that's been studied
by microwaves that's for NIGMS get a 30
mar 14 go get them all fast forward many
papers later we text mine to find these
things we eyeball them to make sure we
got know what we're getting that's an HR
biotech we know how to map fe agilent
arrays to the latest gene identifiers
that's a nature methods you know how to
deke involve complex multicellular
samples to single cell samples that's in
nature methods all the papers on talk
about any of the methodology it tends to
get really boring i'm going to show you
what we're doing with this fast forward
now you have a big grid 300-plus
diseases this way 20,000 genes this way
and we know how much every gene is
changing in every experiment okay
including leprosy marfans asthma
salmonella these are all diseases people
have studied for the aficionados in the
audience we text mine we actually
started using meta map now we use
something from the NC BL the center for
biomedical ology we code everything with
snowmen and represented in umls we love
you i'm allison in the lab is just the
best way to represent these things
because you can join with icd-9 icd-10
and snow matt is what the pathologist
have been using for 70-plus years it's
probably gonna make the basis of icd-11
so we'd sno-med code everything the
statistical folks in audience we rank
normalize and scale every measurements
we destroy any distribution that might
have been in our array lowest Geno chip
gets a zero highest you know trip gets a
one with equally spaced fractions in
between so it's fairly brain-dead types
of and we have methods to show that that
that actually works the best for us now
while we're building the deceased side
it turns out huge lab like the Broad
Institute have been doing the same thing
on the drug side so Justin lab and Todd
God came up with something called a
connectivity map where they launched
with 150 draw first was like a hundred
fifty drugs that they had a thousand
drugs and now they're launching
something called links which has 5,000
drugs in it
they take a whole bunch of cancer cells
and say what is the microwave what is it
gene expression look with drug without
drunk with drug without drug with drug
without with drug a distance and that
those zanottis without drugs they tried
different doses many different drugs and
we start to realize we can partner these
two public data sets together I'll make
the statistic super simple with my arms
if I've got a disease where I got this
gene going up and this gene going down
and now we've got a drug that makes this
gene go down and this gene go up maybe
there's a match there ok and that's two
genes imagine 20,000 genes and imagine a
statistic a negative correlation here
now we're not brain-dead here we know
not every drug goes to for example the
brain brought blood-brain barrier so you
look a lot of non computational things
to know what to pursue here but boy you
know what we start to realize is that
not only can we do is would just random
drugs we can start to find new uses for
drugs drug repositioning under what's
called drug repurposing it's got a great
history of finding new uses for drugs I
mean you know the famous engine a drug
that had an annoying side effect of hair
growth that is today what we have
minoxidil people know that was
repositioned before it actually really
even came out in the trials of course
the classic example everyone knows about
it's another interesting cardiac drug
very interesting side effect patients
don't want to give the drug back after
the endo trial equals viagra today now
everyone knows the viagra story I think
very few people realize that viagras
double done this right we have another
cover revatio same molecule that's
supposedly indicated for pulmonary
hypertension opens those blood vessels
do from the heart to the lungs okay but
you know what instead of finding these
by accident why don't we try to find
them on purpose using public big data
here and these computational methods so
how are we going to do this well you
know I can find a drug and here's a drug
for you know for heart attack and it
seems like it's going to work in
muscular dystrophy maybe I should just
try a drug for this disease and try it
in a kid with I even before i put in a
kid i'm just going in a mouse model for
a couple thousand dollars right that's
how it's done why i'm going to skip
through this all right why are we going
to do this and what are we going to do
first turn
crank first story we get epilepsy drug
topiramate called topamax it's a change
a jog now off-patent billman generic we
think works on crohn's disease
inflammatory bowel disease so from the
brain to the vowel and we make a kind of
grid like this this is truncated here
and these are all different drugs and we
see steroids look like they're going to
reverse the effect of inflammatory bowel
disease we know that one works we treat
patient with stories all the time we
don't like it gets down at long term but
better than store it seems to be
topiramate would make an amazing
scientific story of this one work so
it's a no brainer we're going to test it
seems better than steroids and those you
can just see this this is just eyeball
it right here's crows Aziz these genes
are in general are up these are down and
here's the pyramid here's down here's up
so I'm just trying to show eyeball it
that we're reversing the effect if you
look across the genome so we start to
work with collaborators on campus we
start with j patrick mahan chinoy GI
folks the way to do this is you get a
rat we have to learn i'm not a GI expert
we've got to learn how to do this read
some papers terms i get rats you squirt
TN vs up where the Sun don't shine and
you start to get the inflammation in the
bowels to put steroids it seems to
reduce that effect there's still some
infiltrate treatment topiramate seems to
reverse the effect now we love these
guys mohan and jay we submit this
essentially some medicine the editors
come back and say guys do you have any
better date on this one i love those too
but they were giving us iphone pictures
of the colon okay not the highest
resolution camera i love these guys we
knew the drug was working but not the
best data so we'd any better data editor
for better dare we said okay Jay we love
you're going to outsource this one as a
depo hundred companies come back to us
in 24 hours we pick one out of Berkeley
kind of because they're having a sale
for the same price everyone else they're
giving us all these serum cytokines
inflammatory markers Suffolk illuminates
betta say so we get tnf alpha levels
kind of useful for this so I ok we're
going with you guys and then we pick up
company out in Cambridge Massachusetts
freaking expensive but the only ones in
the world who knew how to do a rat
colonoscopy this is a normal rat colon
this is a rapid Crohn's disease or
inflammatory bowel disease with the T
NBS you can see it here
and there's a rat with dnbs now with the
topiramate now you know I'm not just
cherry picking the images for you I have
40 megs of video with the paper you go
look to see what the colon looks like
you're now why is this important it's
important point to realize as a
computational person I'm not just
outsourcing this stuff to save money I'm
outsourcing this to get the best damn
data in the world nobody on campus knew
how to do a rat colonoscopy those are
you kind of chuckling maybe are over age
50 and you've done the geometry here
this is a colonoscope and this is a rat
okay sagada really has a special skill
to know how to do this okay this is
exactly the kind of experiment you want
to outsource okay someone else can
figure out how to do this so we do this
all the time now to companies that give
us the same answers plus our own on
campus collaborators we really know this
drug is working and out goes a company
spin-out company it just turns the crank
computationally as a business model here
without working for other cancers i'm
going to show you this one here okay
this is one of most product we've done
six of these six out of six have worked
in animal models okay for more papers
comment out one by one by one this one
I'm really proud of this is a drug this
is first of all a mouse that gets its
own lung cancer if you're not got p53
rbp 130 it's a triple knockout it gets
its own small cell lung cancer so you
got to wait weeks for it to get cancer
but you can see nodules or your
projector is great the lighting is
perfect in see nodules here and this is
a mouse same Mouse treated with an
antidepressant still in the pharmacy but
the psychiatrist don't really use this
antidepressant anymore because they've
moved on to better antidepressants but
this one had some annoying side effects
nothing as bad as having lung cancer
though okay and this antidepressant is
melting the tumors this is neat this is
a sixth one that's worked for us okay we
got transplant drugs with a lot of these
things coming up why am i proud of this
one because we went from computational
prediction we got a working cell lines
in a dish I'm going to show you that we
got the mouse model working 15 months
later after the computation we got IRB
approval and now we have two patients
already recruited at Stanford on this
drunk and
this is the new world for us as
computational scientists as informatics
folks why do we keep thinking we're
handing this off to someone most of time
it has to come down to us to run with
our ideas right and nothing is stopping
us from doing this 15 months hell I
think we could do it way faster now that
we know this is our new finish line
right for us we thought we got to work
in a mouse that's a great finish line no
the real finish lines to get into
patients right and this how much is this
trial costs we got an internal seed
grant cancer center seat grab $25,000
grant because it's already in the
pharmacy here right sometimes clinical
trial isn't a billion dollars or even a
million dollars maybe that seed clinical
trial only cost a couple thousand
dollars and your institution might
already be giving you ready to give you
money to run with your ideas the point
is is that it doesn't end with the
computer might not even end with the
mouse it might really ends the reason we
are all in medical schools is to do
something about it with patients and
healthcare providers here so we have 10
sub stories come in like this you can
see the papers that my usual rotation
project now for our grad student is go
figure out a drug for this disease in 10
weeks I like what you do maybe we'll
keep you in the lab okay but that's what
a Genentech would spread I guess six
years doing that's what they gotta do in
10 weeks now right I think kid can do
this today especially grad student maybe
even an undergrad here so I don't have
five minutes left so I'm going to just
end with my big picture oky systems
medicine where I think this field is
going and I'll leave a couple minutes of
questions here but I think about
fast-forward where all the problems
aren't your health system and mine and
all across the world it comes down to
patients and patient care with chronic
disease in the end okay why I go off to
cancers becomes its primary chronic
disease diabetes is chronic disease
obesity most of my field pediatrics is
disappearing weekly right we don't have
kids with meningitis anymore we way more
care about kids that are obese because
we're gonna get this adult disease later
right chronic disease is all about it we
have these patients we want them to head
towards good outcomes here's a patient
heading towards a good outcome but you
know once in a while they diverge and
they head towards a poor outcome and we
only get to see them every once in a
while whether it's at a clinic or the
exam room but I'm calling biomedical
moments right we don't get to see them
will
with them the circles maybe are getting
closer because it might be tracking them
with mobile health and patient portals
we already get to see them once in a
while and once or well we just want to
keep them heading towards a good outcome
but we once or I'll see they're heading
towards a poor outcome now the whole
entire country into our world is focused
on what in the patient's genetics and
genomics there's going to keep this
patient heading towards a good outcome
instead of a poor outcome but you know
what I'm going to be the first admit we
can have an entire human genome sequence
on a patient if they can't afford the
meds they're going to head towards a
poor alka by don't care how many base
pairs you have if they live in a field
next to a pesticide they're going to get
a problem no matter how many base pairs
you've sequenced what in the social and
environment also help alters this
outcome but actually you know what you
can have the entire genome sequence on a
patient you can make sure every patient
can afford the meds they deserve some
day we'll get there the United States
but if we can't practice quality care
these two don't matter if we don't even
have our act together in that biomedical
moment to keep them in the right
direction to get a Huber goal of an a1c
on a diabetic and all the rest they're
still going to head towards a poor
outcome now why am i mentioning it this
way because we have genetics and
genomics we have social and
environmental health of quality of care
each one of these is incredibly
data-driven today meaning that we at
least have measurements in these fields
but these are some of the most siloed
organizations today how often does the
geneticists really talk to the
behavioral scientists talk to the Qi
person in the hospital but actually the
mission is all the same they're all
trying to help this patient head towards
a good outcome and to me the future is
being able to learn from every patient
apply this to every patient from each of
these three arrows earlier earlier in
real time it's what the government would
call a learning healthcare system that's
what I would call a data driven systems
medicine approach so take one points
here molecular clinical epidemiology
cool data and tools already exist
they're there for you to play with
integrated cross data is incredible
bioinformatics is got to be more than
just building tools and websites the
world doesn't need yet another website
if you think you have the best killer
app the best killer algorithm method
show the world what you
onde with it not just the URL for your
website if you built your tool you know
it best show people what you find with
it but this is the hardest part is how
do we find new investigators are willing
to launch their career on other people's
data you know it's a hard story I don't
trust any one of these data sets okay
but I trust what's the wisdom of the
crowd across the scientists and today
weren't able to do this always looking
for postdocs I couldn't I mean this or
long list of collaborators I have
endowment support friendly self out for
a confrontational to help alive has 17
NIH grants from these nine institutes of
NIH these four give me more these five
give me less I still love them March of
Dimes HPA to my Cancer Foundation's I
think my admin tech stuff all the time
I'd never get a grander paper had to go
without them I always think my wife
microbiologist Bob chemist leads all the
big papers against that comes out of my
lab starts companies with me now and
lets me go all over the place to give
talks like this thank you very much I
think I left a couple minutes for
questions I won't be offended if you run
out the room yeah thanks thanks for very
interesting and lightning talk what I'd
like to do is when people with a few
minutes for questions is hand you the
microphone because we're recording this
so that way we'll capture the question
so let me run up to Suzie and so I don't
know how to ask this but what are your
grant applications look like and how do
you what am I crab fishing expeditions
tell them I'll tell you how exactly my
grants look like okay so first of all
you have to be this huge element of
grantsmanship involved here okay but my
grants typically look like em one is--
look at this cool computational method i
have working like here are my papers and
what I'm going to make it better into
I'm going to prove to you why it's
working better with evaluation in silico
let's say this data said that they said
compare it to the other methods and aim
three here's real biology I'm going to
run with this method okay and I make it
collaborators who have signed they're
going to run with anything I predict
this disease of that disease or increase
your might to say
got a company we might have found them
with a Sadie Paul might not even mention
that's it you Bob just going to quote in
there saying this company is ready to
run with this experiment now you got to
be obviously cognitive what's going on
here right if i say i'm going to ask a
deeper this mouse experiments send this
grant to a mouse study section they will
laugh me out of the room okay i grant
you that right but if you send a grant
to and a lamb or computational study
section well again I have to think also
they're seeing someone actually wants to
try this idea right instead of just
leaving it for someone else that great
unknown people to hit a website you're
actually going to try this idea seems to
work for me seems to work for study
sections so it means sharing some of the
money okay not to stick it all for you
as a junior faculty share with experts
who are actually there to get get your
success just as much as you want your
success does answer your question what
what types of skills are people coming
into this field needing yeah what skills
are people in eating so this is a
complication so for the molecular side
we so what it really comes down to is we
need more quantitative thinkers in our
field okay and what often that means is
people sometimes go to biology and
medicine because they saw at least in
all these you can't stand the
quantitative engineering side of things
right the reason why I keep talking
about high school students right it's
just to show people look how fun it can
be learning biology in high school when
you look at 30,000 breast cancer samples
inside of dissecting frogs right with
formaldehyde that's not biology doesn't
have to be Balaji could be as cool as
finding a new diagnostic and patenting
it as a high school kid right so it
means keeping the kids and my kids I
mean at all age keep them as
quantitative as thinkers as far as they
can go right so empirically what it
means is today when I look at our
incoming applications for our graduate
programs a lot of them are undergraduate
majors in bio computation there are many
undergrad campuses that have this
certainly stand for brown where I went
to school use the SC UCSD many campuses
and up thinking or building copy
from biology programs it could be housed
in the department company science it
could be a house the Department of
Biology it doesn't really matter that if
students are getting some dual training
and they're going to grad school so
that's going to be those applicants some
of them go to medical school they're
incredible you know computational
biology undergrad to get into medical
schools just incredible story for them
I've seen students where multiple
institutions are trying to woo them to
come with fully funded ms DPS right you
get em be peachy from our part of a
fully fund when they get multiple offers
like that on arrival on campus not at
the end of the day like they're really
getting sought after so try to get
undergrads interested I know you guys
don't have under grants on your campus
here but you have them in your community
maybe that's their pool maybe that's
your pool of future graduates made with
your pool of innovators to do to start
the companies with you guys to thank you
very much for having me